[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal nous
sommes le 12 décembre 2016
voici les titres la ville de versailles
et les promoteurs de nexity dubai
rodamco ont signé vendredi dernier la
vente des terrains du quartier de
versailles chantiers un projet
d'urbanisme verra le jour en 2019 nous y
étions moment de solidarité ce midi à
versailles et plusieurs associations
dead ou migrants ont offert un repas à
des centaines de réfugiés
et puis une date importante a noté le 31
décembre ce n'est pas seulement la date
du jour de l'an mais c'est aussi la date
limite pour s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales
vous en saurez plus sur les démarches à
suivre dans ce journal
je vous le disais dans les titres moment
de solidarité à versailles ce midi
plusieurs associations des deux au
migrant ont offert un repas aux réfugiés
une centaine de réfugiés
nous étions sur place syrien afghan ou
soudanais 120 migrants ont pu profiter
d'un repas chaud au centre 8 de
versailles au menu soupe riz et poté aux
lentilles un moment de partage proposé
aux migrants des centres de versailles
mort te mets et aux concours
c'est une très bonne c'était parce que
dans le cendrier a pas assez elle il n'y
a pas à les nourrir qui sont favorables
[Musique]
l'accueil c'est très bien c'est très
bien organisé très bien préparés ça
permettra de nous connaître et d'en
profiter pour rencontrer et découvrir
des français 170 litres de soupe 3 kg de
pain le déjeuner a été préparé par une
cinquantaine de bénévoles des
associations ar 78 du secours catholique
et de rsf la communauté protestante de
versailles a accepté de prêter ses
locaux pour témoigner de sa solidarité
il ya eu beaucoup de manifestations anti
il ya eu des phrases terribles qu'on a
entendu donc on veut montrer que
versailles accueille je vous promets que
les bénévoles se sont mis vraiment en
marche et au boulot sans aucun souci
pour nous c'était faire donc leur offrir
un repas un peu améliorée par rapport à
leur ordinaire créer un mot un disons un
moment de convivialité
donc entre mais aussi entre
les migrants arrivés dans un centre est
et les migrants arrivés dans un autre
parce que jusqu'ici il n'avait pas de
contact d'entre eux un moment de
convivialité aussi avec tous les
bénévoles d'autres déjeuner pourrait
être organisée par le collectif
en octobre les yvelines accueillait 400
réfugiés les migrants devraient être
réorientés dans différents centres sur
toute la france la ville de versailles
et les promoteurs de nexity d'unibail
rodamco ont signé vendredi dernier la
vente des terrains du quartier de
chantier à versailles un projet
d'urbanisme d'envergure sortira de terre
en 2019
il aura fallu seize ans pour parvenir à
cette signature signature qui permettra
à un projet d'urbanisme de changer la
face du quartier chantier à versailles
un dispositif important pour lequel le
maire de versailles françois de mazières
s'est battu je crois qu'on peut être
très content parce que c'est un projet
qui remonte
à plusieurs années on a tous beaucoup
travaillé dessus je pense qui correspond
bien à ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui pour
21e siècle c'est un projet qui intègre
la dimension environnementale
l'ancien projet est un projet construit
sur une dalle de béton et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les gens demandent un
équilibre entre le construit la nature
c'est ça qu'on a essayé de faire et
c'est un projet très intéressant parce
que il intègre plusieurs dimensions la
vie des résidences seniors des bureaux
et des logements sont à prévoir au total
quarante cinq mille mètres carrés le
tout dessiné par deux architectes de
renom elisabeth et christian portzamparc
ça va ressembler à un projet comme
versailles en connaît peu un projet
contemporain un projet ouvert un projet
avec une forte présence d'un espace
public dg talent arboré avec des
bâtiments qui rayonne sur l'extérieur et
des bâtiments qui mélangent leurs
fonctions un grand mélange des gens est
une énergie qui n'est pas forcément
celle que versailles que nos quotidiens
dans dans une architecture est belle
mais qui date du viiie siècle
le nouveau projet d'urbanisme du
quartier de versailles chantiers sortira
de terre en 2019
l'année prochaine sera marquée par deux
élections majeures les présidentielles
fin avril début mai et les législatives
qui se dérouleront au mois de juin
mais pour voter il faut s'inscrire sur
les listes électorales et ça concerne
ceux qui ont déménagé on fait le point
avec mélanie poker on saura alors
l'échéance approche et c'est même plus
proche qu'on ne le pense vous avez donné
les dates des scrutins osm mais pour les
inscriptions des sur les listes le délai
encore plus court la fin c'est le 31
décembre à 23h59 donc plus que trois
semaines pour s'inscrire et
particularité cette année le 31 décembre
thomas
samedi donc les services municipaux
ferme ta midi ce qui fait demi journées
en moins pour s'inscrire
alors quelles sont les démarches à
suivre alors il y a plusieurs
possibilités on peut se rendre
directement à la mairie sur place on
vous fera remplir un formulaire cerfa
pour gagner du temps vous pouvez aussi
l'imprimé le remplir de chez vous on le
trouve facilement sur internet
alors on valoir aussi il ya plusieurs
documents apportés le cerfa qu'elle
avait des documents présentés
il faut aussi avoir une pièce d'identité
et un justificatif de domicile plusieurs
documents sont acceptés les factures les
factures de gaz ou d'électricité
citer les factures de téléphone il y
aussi les déclarations d'impôts et même
les quittances de loyer et le passage en
mairie après qu'on attrape des cons à
tout ça ça prend moins de 5 minutes
car il fallait pas agent administratif
de la ville de plaisir nous donne la
suite du calendrier
alors avant la carte d'électeur ils
reçoivent un récépissé d'inscription qui
rappelle leur état civil et qui leur
indiquent leurs bureaux de vote
une fois que le dossier bien sûr passer
en commission électorale et la carte
électorale n'arrive que courant mars
2010 est donc on peut aussi s'inscrire
sur internet via le site service
public.fr mais je crois que toutes les
communes ne sont pas concernés en effet
sur sur 50 ans domine c'est le cas de
maurepas les clayes-sous-bois
d'elancourt de villepreux et de la
verrière elles ne sont pas reliés au
service gouvernemental
il faut donc se déplacer à tous les
coups avec une année électorale
présidentielle les inscriptions il faut
le savoir elle explose parce qu'à
plaisir d'habitude ce sont entre 300 et
500 nouvelles demandes d'inscriptions
pour une année de présidentielle comme
celle de 2017 leurs services enregistre
plus de 2500 inscriptions et pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas le temps de
s'inscrire ou qui auraient même oublié
il restera juste la procuration
merci mélanie poker avec près de 400
mille nouveaux cas de cancers détectés
chaque année le cancer est un fléau pour
l'homme même si le nombre de décès a
tendance à diminuer
et cela grâce à la prévention un
reportage de nicolas gandrille
rencontres et échanges entre les
professionnels de santé sur le cancer
c'était l'objectif de la table ronde
organisée vendredi 9 décembre à l'ufr
des sciences de l'université versailles
saint quentin
le but renforcer la lutte contre le
cancer dans les yvelines
on s'est aperçus qu'au niveau de notre
agglomération où on a un pourcentage
quand même de cancers du sein un peu
plus élevé que sur les autres
agglomérations bouvron l'institut de
promotion de la santé basée à trappes
est engagé dans cette lutte
son rôle développer la prévention et
faire connaître les offres de soins du
territoire avec l'accent qui est mis sur
le dépistage précoce pour permettre une
guérison efficace on souhaite multiplier
ses actions de prévention notamment par
le dépistage en sachant qu'il ya
d'autres voies pour pour la prévention
il faut également parler de notre ition
de diététique
il faut également parler de prévention
des addictions c'est faire en sorte que
les professionnels de santé connaissent
également toutes les ressources du
territoire puisse connaître également
la façon d'orienter au mieux et de façon
optimum
il est public et patients en france le
taux de guérison et croissants en 2015 3
millions de français ont survécu au
cancer elancourt organisé le week end
dernier son marché de noël sur la place
du général de gaulle au programme douze
chalets pour les artisans locaux avec
leurs produits animations comme le snow
park ou encore le mur d'escaladé moment
à partager en famille
la trouille mois qu'il vertige d'origine
en à dire c'est ça fait bizarre c'est
impressionnant et puis on est on est
crispé on est en hésitant quand je
pousse et une prise
et moi j'avais peur de tomber et de me
faire mal j'ai fait du skateboard sur la
neige c'est elle et des saintes à peu
près c'est un peu compliqué mais sinon
j'ai réussi je suis pas tombé g
les défenses qu'en descente et c'était
un peu dia c'était un peu dur la
descente et attrapes l'association dès
commerçants et la croix-rouge organisé
vendredi soir à la salle jean baptiste
clément
la remise officielle des jouets de noël
dans le cadre de la 4ème édition de
l'opération collecte de jouets porté par
l'agencé century 21 cette année ils ont
retenu cinq mille neuf cents jouets pour
les enfants
écoutez à ce propos houria elhadj l'une
des responsables de l'opération
l'objectif c'était d'organiser en fait
le côté attrait du ministre et
humanitaire de la ville de trappes
trappe on entend parler souvent à
mauvais escient rose qui n'est pas la
réalité c'est pas la réalité du terrain
donc on avait envie d'être acteur local
en tant que commerçant proximité
montrez là peut-être compétitive tout
cette complicité pardon les habitants
sur cette colline autre distribution de
jouets celle du réseau stibus depuis 20
ans l'entreprise organise une collecte
au sein de l'agglomération
la redistribution avait eu lieu cet
après midi dans la salle du café de la
plage de maurepas elles ont pu se
partager une collecte record
laurence guillod et la responsable
commerciale et communication de ski bus
on a eu beaucoup de joie neufs qui sont
arrivés au centre commercial saint
quentin ça mercredi et samedi
1 j étais vraiment les gens allaient
acheter des jouets chez oxybul juste en
face pour nous les offrir
donc c'est assez c'est une générosité
exceptionnel cette année et c'est vrai
aussi que tout s'est joué dans ses deux
salles c'est impressionnant j'ai un
salarié ce matin de ski bus qui est
passé qui n'avait jamais fait cette
opération avec nous et qui ne revenait
pas à me dit mais je me rendais pas
compte que c'était on était 26 pour
vider le bus ce matin on a commencé à
9h30 on a fini à 12h30 à 26 à ranger à
trier les jouer avez vous entendu parler
du mannequin challenge cette pratique
viral sur les réseaux sociaux consiste à
se filmer deux en position immobile et
bien vous allez voir que cette vague a
aussi passé les portes de la gendarmerie
départementale à versailles et la vidéo
est plutôt une réussite avec plus de
32000 vues sur youtube
je vous laisse la découvrir
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce cette ut le journal
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]